so how do you take a photo or a piece of
footage and a piece of type and how do
you arrange them and align them so that
they look visually pleasing to the eye
that's we're going to talk about on
today's video podcast
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the video
podcast the emotion science podcast my
name is Cameron and welcome so today
what we're in is we're going to go over
an interesting very simple but yet
interesting technique to help you align
things when you're designing in motion
design and this is like I said simple
but very powerful ok so what we're going
to do is we're going to start willing to
do two examples here we're gonna start
with photograph one which you can see
here is a photograph if I scale this
puppy down it's just a road I found this
on the unsplash so that was kind of cool
and I've got sitting here inside of the
composition here it's 1920 by 1080 the
framerate doesn't matter and the
duration doesn't matter because this is
about design I'm teaching you about
design here and these are very simple
principles that are very powerful to
make your your imagery look way more
powerful okay so let's protect maybe
this is a title sequence we all know
title sequences so let's just type in
the word strange days and that works
great for me you're gonna notice that my
color here is because I'm going to do
some testing I sampled a little bit of
blue from this color you don't want to
have it be straight-up white or
straight-up black it's just gonna be
kind of ugly for this you know maybe
straight up white would kind of work but
actually if I was gonna go white I
probably sample the whites in this which
is slightly off-white well let's just go
back and kind of pick a dark color maybe
like that and so we've got our text and
we've got our image and I'll here's the
trick okay we're going to go up to After
Effects preferences grids and guides and
we're gonna make sure under proportional
grid right here that we want this to be
set to 3x3 yours may have a different
number but 3x3 is going to create a
proportional grid that when we go down
here to our grid and guide options and
we turn on proportional grid boom there
we go we've got our once section one
vertical section two vertical section
three vertical so it's it's a rule of
thirds right we've got a top section
here a middle section and a bottom
section so we've got rule of thirds
horizontally and vertically the rule of
thirds tells me that this is a great
focal point this is a
very vocal vocal point this is another
great focal point and this is a great
focal point okay so our rule of thirds
is on all we have to do now is just
let's just turn off our type let's just
focus on the image okay so let's just
scale this image down to something like
70% and it's really interesting to see
this this line in the road here so I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna bring this line up
so it lines up with this rule of thirds
line and I'm gonna hold down shift and
bring this over to the right here and
I'm just going to have it move off into
the distance right here at an
interesting focal point okay so if I
turn off by proportional grid it already
looks a little bit more interesting okay
so let's turn it back on let's turn on
our text and now let's make our text
focus in on another interesting point
which is going to be right here okay so
we're aligning the center of this text
with the center of this point that blue
color is not going to work so let's go
with a white and boom there we go look
how beautiful that layout is and it's
very simple I'm just using a very simple
rule of thirds to create that now let's
look at a second example now in this
example example two I've got an
interesting house over a lake it's very
kind of spooky so let's say this is a
title sequence for like a maybe a horror
film or mystery film or something like
that so what we're gonna do here so
we're going to arrange this image using
the rule of thirds again so if I turn on
proportional grid right here remember
this is my rule of thirds because I went
up to our preferences grids and guides
and I said let's make it three by three
okay and all I have to do now is just
find an interesting scale point so let's
maybe go up to maybe a scale of 80 and
let's make this front door be our center
point right so look at that that's our
that's our interesting point of or
interesting focal point right there okay
so it looks pretty good let's turn on
our text and we're using this
interesting Underwood 1913 font typeface
and I've typed in the word the haunting
and again I don't want this to be
sitting over here
that's not so great but if we go the
opposite like we did on the first
example we go to the opposite point of
interest for the rule thirds right here
look how interesting that looks all
right so let's find like let's find
maybe a yellow maybe a little bit two
white men let's just go a little bit
more on the yellow side there and let's
turn off a proportional grid and look at
that that is beautiful because we're
using a very simple technique called the
rule thirds and if you use this this
technique when you're designing and
you're laying out motion design whether
it be a photo or footage or typography
or shape layers whatever it is use the
rule of thirds to create better looking
motion design thanks for watching the
video blog
as always I'm Cameron and this is motion
science
[Music]